[Music]
david is in waco texas hi david how are
you
good hi mr ramsey hi dr d thanks for
having me great how can we help um so
mike
yeah my question is i got a house
question for you guys
my grandfather did well in his career
and lived well below his means so he set
up a trust account for each of
his grandchildren me included so
currently the trust account is about 1.1
million dollars
and so one of the reasons or one of the
few ways that i can use the trust
account before age 40
isn't buying a house and so my wife and
i are currently looking at buying a
house
and so i was just wondering you know how
much would you spend from the trust on
that house
and then also i just wanted to confirm
that you would buy that house in full
using the money oh absolutely i pay cash
for it
no doubt about it what's your household
income
so it was 120 last year i'm going to
take the year off to get a master's
degree in accounting
and so my wife's income is going to be
50 000
so then once i get my degree then it'll
go back up
okay i don't know why you have to take
time off to get a master's in accounting
you can do that in the evenings yeah
every single one of my grad degrees
was working full-time but that's a
different phone call i guess
here's what i would tell you in there in
waco you can
buy a house that is 185 000 that's a
remarkable home and then you can go
bananas
and buy a million dollar house so what
are you thinking about spending
yeah so our we were thinking somewhere
you know i don't know in 300 range
our total max would be 400 we don't want
to do more than that but
i think that's fine pay cash for it and
then uh but i'm i'm also
going to challenge you to rethink taking
a year off i think you just go to class
in the evenings and finish your masters
yeah in accounting
but without getting into the detail of
it i'm just i'm just challenging you to
rethink that i'm with you i think it'll
be better for everybody
yeah but aside from that 120 150 000
income 400 000 paid for house how the
trust makes sense oh make sure you're
paying yourself a house payment after
that
so that you become wealthy like your
grandpa that'd be an idea pay it forward